what is up everybody its Anna Mack aka
your boy mr. your girl calls me senpai
over here here for anime uproar and
welcome to another episode of red cafe
this episode we're gonna be ranting
about Shonen anime current Shonen anime
what's awaiting shortened anime in the
future all that stuff so stay tuned for
that it's gonna be other lovely
discussion with me I have now Bogata is
back Oh pleasure to have you back now we
got NOx Taku in the house again we have
to have this guy we all tell NOx talk
because if we don't a bunch of fans will
complain in the comments yeah that's
right I love you guys and we also have
anime recon the favourite victim of NOx
talk whose savagery yeah I'm doing well
let's get this started shall we
I was seriously considering implementing
a running joke on the chat on my channel
where I make fun of you so this is a
heads up you make wait you're gonna make
fun of me on your channel yeah go ahead
Catriona me I might react to it yeah not
yet what would eat until you hit 400,000
subscribers it's gonna be a while first
I have to do another one on noble one on
Joey one a double for anime and then we
can worry what is in double for animes
whole channel a sarcastic trailer that's
a long list anyway I'm not good I like
it's drama that I'm not directly
involved with even though we're friends
so I'm looking forward to seeing what
happens there or not I guess I don't
think you can actually do anything aside
from just take his shirt off and scream
by the way I'm currently drinking among
out of an official anime uproar among
guys holy crap oh look at that Wow
rip but if you prefer head cut
poor guys you can get this one yes yeah
I mentioned this last time in last rank
affair but now the merge anima / merge
store is up and running if you want to
check the description you can buy shirts
our own unique designs we came up with
all of it ourselves especially with the
hentai stuff so if you can check you
want to check that out
proceeds go to helping the channel and
you can get a mug that says hentai on it
I think it's a win-win situation
so how much is that anime uproar mug um
you have to check because you can look
at the design and then put designs on a
mug I think a mug is like 14 or
something like that but I'm not a
hundred percent sure
plus they always some discounts they
have are currently like a like an thirty
percent discount on the site so it
varies are you gonna do a boy Friday
discount I don't control the discounts
like those people look I vote we talk
about Shonen anime another you know an
hour of promoting different mugs and
t-shirts that's how you got to do it you
got to do your sponsors ago thank your
sponsors yeah I want to thank my
sponsors myself because once Nolan spawn
you got to think yourself sometimes and
pat yourself on the back because you're
doing it it's important why don't we
shout out to everyone in the chat as
well I forgot to shot you guys out
all right knocks since you want to talk
about own an anime the current situation
which draw an anime in the future for an
enemy you can start with something
insightful no pressure okay
Gintama is awesomeness and none of you
watch it so none of you can really talk
about how Shonen anime is going to pot
because you're missing out on the best
one going on right now okay guys can I
hear in the chat it does anyone watch
Gintama also I just want to point out
that knock stock who just said that
Gintama is better than one piece wow
recon you're so cool you don't watch
them so you don't exactly so I don't
give a [ __ ] only once I watch this fairy
tale
that is what I give a [ __ ] about
recon every by watching Gotama I love
you guys see by the way shuttles in the
child what's up my man I haven't seen
you in a while I know you've been busy
but welcome back the thing is like I
know I've seen over 100 anime oh I don't
seem like a thousand like mystique remix
the other but even I look down on you
recon for watching like 12 anime all
together in your life I don't want to
look I mean if you only watched 12 anime
and you want to talk about those 12
anime you have you know full power full
speed to you
have fun but don't diss anime you
haven't seen just because you haven't
seen them that is a very good point very
good point nukes and I appreciate you
shouting I'll get them I haven't watched
it but you sent me some clips that are
pretty hilarious so I definitely think
that it's one of the type of type of
genre with a heavy dose of comedy that I
would enjoy if I bother comedy is so
different than any other comedy you see
in anime I would rate it the number one
comedy anime like of all time yeah
without thinking twice oh it's such a
different such a different style humour
and the serious arcs are so you know
dramatic also they put almost everything
else to shame it's a perfect blend oh it
really is it just hurts my one piece is
so good one piece is great the manga is
pretty great the anime is pretty not yes
you know seven minutes of recap of the
last episode in the last four minutes
our previews to the next episode there's
three minutes of opening and ending
theme songs and the rest of the time is
just crappy animation there's there's a
seer there's a part in one case where
the animation like it starts off crap
and then it gets really really good and
then it gets excellent and then it goes
right to [ __ ]
so the waito waito animation works is if
they're ever doing two shows at the same
time at least one of them is gonna be
it's gonna look like pasta
yeah and now right now they're doing
Dragon Ball super in one piece and I
don't want to keep for sure
maestra quality I know for Dragon Ball
super and as far as the one piece the
way the anime is going right now there's
this one fight Luffy versus cracker okay
fighting cracker and it's like one
chapter of manga and it's I think seven
episodes of anime it's cracker of
villain crackers just would he be named
cracker he's just a white guy pretty
minor villain it's a guy named cracker
what are you asking questions it's just
such an odd name it's just such an odd
name to be in for a villain to be called
cracker I mean cracker is a villain just
doesn't sound yeah you know what's a
better name death gun yeah that's what I
like better than [ __ ] cracker Yosef
gun sounds like it's like if there was
like a metal band in the 80s like man it
was a satire of bands like spinal tap
like death ganja you know that er it's a
fourteen-year-old kid who's upset at
life
gorgeous go back asked are we talking
about black hole where we definitely
will cuz I think black is whether you
think it's good or not I think it's an
important telltale sign of what may and
or may not be coming in terms of Shonen
yeah in the next little while also
narutards said that he loves shingeki no
kyojin or attack on titan interesting
enough he didn't mention naruto your
nose name is not [ __ ] pink or punk
punk so you say anything or the borough
tardes are gonna come get him oh the
board starts would be like hey you
should call yourself boruto or too bad
[ __ ] not narutards oh nice
I have to get recon to just laugh after
whatever I say then we cover our bases
yep but but yeah so in terms of I don't
know if you want to talk more about
Gintama but in terms of black clover I
think it's really interesting and cuz I
know quite a few people who like the
manga but are disappointing with the
anime adaptation and it makes me wonder
in terms of long-running Shonen are we
going to be seeing a lot more successful
run long-running Shonen in the future
obviously attack on titan is not a
long-running show and it's a shounen but
it's not you know multiple hundreds of
episodes that type of stuff are we gonna
see these types of short and even
succeed in the future am i near academia
is the most recent one that I think that
really succeeded but it's all that's
already been going on a while or any two
seasons and the manga has been going on
for a long time so are we gonna see this
in future because it seems to me like
there's a lot more focus on quantity
than quality nowadays in the anime
industry so they'll make more of these
like 13-episode edgy cheap series like
you know can shakers and how'd you meant
to know gal and all these bunch of
series okonjima Tino gal gal yeah I did
wow wow man recons favorite anime before
but these series are not gonna be
long-running shown endure your you know
light novel based few episodes gets
short term profit because of the edgy
and stuff and then you move on so I
wonder if the industry is gonna keep
focusing on that and then we're gonna
lose potential to have like a
long-running shown and that's an actual
commitment to the characters to the
story there's an issue with that and
that is there a demongo to adapt that
are that long in that hype everything
that's long and hyped is already adapted
so my hero academia would get to that
point where it could be a long anime if
they would adapt start adapting it in
like five years but they'd rather do it
in you know twenty five or thirteen
episode stints yeah but the question is
how long will it go on so
if it goes on for a lot of time that's
okay if it ends up being a long enemy in
the long run that's fine with me but I'm
saying even with manga if you if you're
a manga connoisseur soul isn't here with
us today because he is at work
unfortunately but he knows of a manga
and I'm wondering do you see any shounen
jump manga in the future becoming the
next one piece cuz I don't see right now
on the horizon anything that could rival
something like one piece or Naruto etc
we're doing well Gintama is a whole
different ball game it's not it's not in
the same league as your power fantasy
where the kid is trying to become strong
it's it's it's own thing that's why it's
so amazing like it's really not
comparable to anything else I think I
think it's just one of those you know
what I mean people see Studios look at
one piece you know what I mean and DBZ
and Naruto and all these really
successful you know Shonen you know what
I mean
and they try to rival it in some kind of
way and I think they're just testing the
waters right now you know what I mean
like seeing what the public is going to
react to are you gonna react to shorter
you know what I mean like the manga
being adapted into like you know more
chapters into one episode or is it going
to influence the audience more if they
make it longer and you can kind of see
how they're testing it with boku no hero
and black clover and like you know what
I mean and how they're doing stuff
recently with one piece as well you know
what I mean I feel like they're still
testing grounds I could see why you're
saying that about my hero and black
clover but what's funny is and what
makes me think they're not testing it is
studio pierrot is crap and therefore
black clover is done terribly boom I
wouldn't agree with that I mean it was
bad at the beginning I must say it was
it was so bad the voice actor really is
annoying and all that stuff but the
stories I did I know three episodes that
adapt one chapter really understand that
I understand that but I
feel like it's starting to get better I
feel like it's getting better
that is the problem though and I think
manga is a good thing to look at because
with light novels they tend to become
anime that are you know you're a few
episodes 13 after those 26 episodes and
then they move on with weekly manga you
can make it into a longer anime but the
problem is catching up to the manga and
making sure that you don't overtake the
manga when you're making them so for
example Dragon Ball super they keep
making it weekly constantly but they're
ahead of the manga because of that
so then manga is playing the catch-up
game so it's difficult to thinking
because yeah like knocks like you said
they made the first chop into three
episodes probably because they're trying
to drag it out so that they don't catch
up to the manga yes
they're already serve right they
scheduled 51 episodes are ready for this
anime
yeah that's why that's probably that's
what it's doing and therefore it did the
first season those 13 episodes are
waited for the manga to go a little
further then it did another season 25
episodes then it's waiting for the manga
to go further it's not all just quantity
quantity like to--a does and like Piero
does yeah black Cobra is definitely
focusing more in quantity than quality
yeah and if you look at my hero academia
they are further ahead the manga is
actually further ahead and black over
but they their first season was 13
episodes the second one was 25 and now
black over is coming out with right away
50 episodes so already they have more
episodes scheduled than my here epidemia
has aired even though the my European
manga is further ahead and again with
Studio Pierrot they also do this thing
with them they just throw down a bunch
of episodes in one shot like hoping
something sticks right before this last
year they did 50 episodes of twin star
Exorcist and if you watch it
no star X is just yes so it wasn't bad
it was nothing amazing the manga was a
hundred times better so it's a studio
thing so this is all this means that
you're only a student working it's the
result for all the hundreds of episodes
of Naruto fillers Nux you know how
Austin's annoying right sure
just just keep watching it then you'll
feel like he's not there anymore
like he's not annoying anyway you're
gonna get used to his voice so I'm
pretty sure that is affected a lot of
people boy you watched first episode and
like oh my god he's so annoying just
keep watching and keep watching it then
you'll notice it's just gone
annoying his voice doesn't help the
thing but he's not annoying because of
his voice
he's annoying because he's stupid and
he's just I don't know he's dumb as mud
he loves done he slams into a pillar oh
my god this pillar wasn't good performer
he's done but he was powerful as well
I'm really gonna start talking about
dumb short and poor diet us because
we'll be here all day like that's not
unique to Blackpool that doesn't make me
like you more just gonna say this right
now
black clover is more better than [ __ ]
Bordeaux in the story just just better
it's better it won't say more better
just better it's better than Barton okay
I will I will actually have Knox comment
on that because I haven't been watching
boruto so I don't know but anti-roman in
the chat says that it's you knows
birthday today guys from mirai nikki so
he says all hail Queenie under it for
lives
interesting interesting tidbit for you
there my way ghoul face fired up ok not
too fired up forgot to change his name
back from Halloween man what's going on
also gorgeous Carmack asked me will you
discuss about dubs in Funimation since
they add their political points to their
dub i dont watch dubs so unfortunately
this is the first I'm hearing about it I
have no idea what's happening dubs think
that I'm even more right than I already
know I am for not I don't they don't
really do political changes as much as
they try to make it fit better for an
American audience that's what they're
doing they're westernizing watch which
is what I hate which is why I don't
watch dogs guys exactly you really let's
it gets really good dubs are terrible
they're always were terrible I got into
a fight with the Canepa effect on
Twitter about the dub for my Haute's
gyno Yomi which is actually pretty solid
dub except they don't have English
accents even though it happy takes place
in England I
watched highschool DxD dub it was good
but there are good dubs yeah there are
they're few and far between thanks even
though good ones have serious issues
like the quote yes one good dub overall
but it has serious issues because it
leaves out parts that you don't know
what that I was actually not being
important and I know because I looked at
code yes very closely I'm sure if I
looked at other anime and the
differences between subs and dubs I
would find plenty of other stuff as well
there are channels on YouTube that
dedicate a lot of time to explaining the
differences between two dubs and subs
cartoon cipher and explanation point
both made multiple videos on this on
Cowboy Bebop in my hair academia tell
baby bops a good example because it was
really done but Cowboy Bebop is the
actual best job of all time I stand is
pretty time is Baca no no cowboy thing
about Cowboy Bebop
the way they bring the characters to
life and how they interact with each
other is freaking amazing and that's
where a lot of voice actors yeah like
their career took off from Cowboy Bebop
and we and we Wes this is this the real
knox in the charts this is the real nuts
in the chat ok so you're not being
impersonated I don't think is that you
knocks the guy that said yo who else
says you know
yo knucks oh I get it I get it
alright I'm gonna make you a moderator
so that now we know it's really you
there you go
good work did I do it you did it
okay cool we did it real Knox is in the
house isn't that exciting that's really
about getting too much into the subs
IRS's dub debate which has been done to
death and you know that I'm a big subs
guy and there are certain exceptions
where dubs are good but I think you need
to let years pass and actually see
especially the series has to be over and
then you know whether the subs and dubs
can be compared because if the series is
ongoing and
dubs make a change that ends up being
screwing up something relevant in the
future like for kids famously that all
the time I'm not saying it'll just
change the language they try to make the
whole thing child-friendly they take out
arcs and they take out scenes that they
don't just change the language no I know
I know I'm like I'm saying for kids is
the extreme example but if you try to
like you said make it more Western
friendly I feel like you might be
actually losing a lot so I would wait
till a series finishes and then compare
the subs and dubs because you don't know
what the mangaka has in mind so if they
make something you know western friendly
and it turns out that actually the
Japanese original translation was
relevant for some reason that comes down
the line that's the kind of stuff I'm
worried about 69 viewers speak hey guys
congratulations guys you just inspiring
a new teacher can anyone take me
seriously while I'm drinking from this
coat and I can no not really
yeah you're seriously promoting your
your merch so all you're doing is
drinking so that people can see your
merch is it right or wrong
to promote me I think you should be
drinking from both mugs at the same time
[Music]
appropriate that's just like what's
happening what's happening I'd like to
thank our sponsor myself oh yeah again
anyway so as far as others showing and
going on now that's actually doing great
shokugeki no souma hug
food wars no one else is watching this
right from recon you know I'm watching
it because of home anime so you know
recon is watching it but no the reason
I'm not watching it is that I haven't
watched the first two seasons and it
would be a big commitment to catch up
but I know from Knox
that he highly recommends it he loves it
he loves the boobs the food however I
need to make a complaint that this
season of food Wars died just three with
recon vehemently he's wrong
you know what I was gonna say you don't
like about this season of food Wars is
that it's work is dealing too much with
the political structure of the school as
far as boobs no that is not what I was
gonna say I was just gonna say that
there is quite minimal minimal she and
in the third season so yeah ah and now
let me explain why when they wanted to
push a cooking shown in everyone was
like what what cooking Shonen why would
I see this man they're like oh because
whenever they eat squid you see girls
getting tentacle raped by squid now of
course you're gonna continue watching
the show no I'm interested no I want to
watch it but now we actually have a
developed cast and it's freaking awesome
'no side from that we know it are you
serious
edginess quite as much wait i need to
know if you're serious because I will
watch it just solely through that reason
it's the first episode ok cool first
episode get two watches yeah I know
I now know Knox enough to know when he's
sarcastic and when he isn't and it's it
is a difficult job to get to the point
but I feel like I'm at that point now so
wow that's cool by the way bulletproof
in the chad says that he thinks that my
eyebrow waggle from earlier sold it so
yes
you got it you got it you got a
deliverer you got a deliverer that
performance every week here in rank of a
perfect performances by everyone
etc by the way recon recon you know how
you said that you're you you want more
fanservice in the third season of food
Wars we had some guy in the comments
section to our last rank a fake
complaining that were idiots because we
say we need to like an anime and I said
I think I said that as a joke I was like
yeah like I think NACA said something or
so I was like yeah but are there boobs
man cuz I need to lose and I said as a
joke and the guy took it seriously the
Congress is like what the [ __ ] hahahaha
appreciate that anyone without boobs and
I was
Internet you can't you know I go through
every single sarcastic video I upload
you can't just have boobs in every
single series that'll be like it's just
too much just have them very knows that
deserve it every not lollies character
should have boobs every non lollies
character yes whether they should you
know wiggle and waggle and dodge bullets
that's that's another story an example
so yeah process send out to made an
abyss wise awesomeness yeah but it's
it's all lollies so you can't really but
it's you're like some anime you don't
watch for fanservice I'm completely okay
with I like I didn't watch mushishi for
fanservice like you're not gonna see
fanservice there you're not gonna see
that even the Psychopaths there's very
little fanservice deathnote very little
fencers right but that's okay you don't
have to watch it for fanservice but
usually the light-hearted anime they
have a lot of fanservice just because it
kind of the one goes hand in hand humor
fanservice it's kind of like a clock I
know it's an interesting topic is like
how fanservice developed itself into
Shonen anime because if you notice like
with a lot of shown in like they do have
like that element of fanservice well it
definitely is an easy way to make money
and it's an easy way to take up time
mm-hmm an example of as dxd good example
that it's shown in what yeah fairy tale
fairy tale is a good example of a
mainstream you know that has quite a bit
of fanservice
whereas even like I would say my hero
academia and these other you know
shounen jump stories they don't have
that much fans're is they'll have a hint
here and there they'll drop it like
mount lady or midnight but it's nothing
too blatant whereas it was way less
fanservice than than the anime even in
fairy tale okay tell us beasts I feel
like one piece has quite a bit
especially like how you know Oda draws
his females you know what I mean they're
either really nice and big or their
soldiers it's like nothing else you see
yeah
but I don't like the females I do I love
I love Otis art I like I love it well
Casta for life says Suzaku fanservice
for Anna Mac no thank you sir please
also soul maka is Loki in the chat using
an alias and complaining that he's not
here for this topic well what can you do
man can you do work work calls you gotta
you know I respect you and next time
hopefully you'll be here someone else
that something I want to comment on oh
yeah someone said something about my
hair academia
do you notice that there's like they
have like a naked chick just walking
around there all the time
that's [ __ ] that's inappropriate
really who is a naked chick horu
invisible girl yeah oh yeah just was not
naked
well wandering off like in battle and
stuff you know I mean share with gloves
they're just gloves and shoes she's
running around we can't really see her
she's running around naked man you know
what really aggravates me I'm sure they
were like in a storm cloud once before
one episode I'm like oh this is great we
finally see what she looks like and
she'll get covered in dirt the girl is
naked we cannot see it I know what
happens if I throw flour on her what
happens she's still naked bro she's
still walking around naked in the middle
of her high school no panties no nothing
man but nobody can see her well she's
not walking around in school like that
she wears a uniform but like I make a
lot of signs but you know not all the
time and what you find is the problem
why is this problem again it's it's it's
just weird that you just have a teenage
girl naked in the anime all the time
sure she's invisible God maybe not there
I don't agree on all the time she is
naked a lot for sure but yeah and if you
throw like a bag of flour on her and
your guys are in the middle of battle
like I throw a bag of flour on you so I
can see where you are so I can
let's see your penis flopping in the
wind my hero academia starts running out
of ideas when the villains have flower
quirks when they get to blow flower in
each other unless she has a special suit
that conforms with their visibility you
know what I mean totally gonna happen
let's be honest most likely the poor
near a mirror you get to see her
reflection what she looks like so it'd
be really funny though like they like
throw bag of flour on our to avoid an
attack just titties flopping in the wind
I'd be pretty funny I still don't agree
that she's getting off topic I disagree
because you were talking about showing
an anime oh yeah that's true it's all
fair game but no in turn in terms of
Tohru I don't understand why she has in
her you know uniform gloves and boots at
all if she's invisible and she wants to
become really invisible then just be
naked like she's already making
everything except balls and foods you
might as well take off the gloves and
boots I agree
like gloves and boots are there so that
we can know where she is she's naked
because people like naked girls in anime
you haven't noticed I don't I don't
understand this debate what's happening
here I guess every female character
almost every female character and I hear
academia has some sort of quirk that
requires them to get naked so she could
pull random crap out of her chest dark
knit midnight whatever her name is
midnight she needs to be naked so that
her pheromone things can put people to
sleep and now lady just her ass takes up
the entire screen all the time like by
the way the darkness and midnight dot
dot that would be a good team for
fighting villainy what anyways I don't
know why hashtag flopping in the wind is
trending in trending in cities flopping
in the wind here what's up man but yes
so in terms of the future of Shonen okay
the reason I think the black clover is a
good example like we don't know how it's
gonna turn out yet but we know that it
started rough Deanna
me because like I said quite a few
people including lost pause remember I
remember made a video on it saying that
he likes the manga quite a bit but the
anime is so far has not proven to be
good and they're dragging it on too much
the voice acting the annoyingness and
I've seen most people so far be
disappointed with the anime although
knocks you pointed out in the past and
with Shonen anime often they take off
after quite a few episodes and really
get good so we still have to give it
some time it's a shounen like if it was
a 13-episode anime and all thirteen
episodes were crap you're done but since
they have 50 who knows but the thing is
if black clover doesn't do that well is
there hope for some other Shonen manga
to actually become a successful
long-running anime or do you see the
industry now way too geared towards
quantity boobs etc to actually bring us
another Naruto or one piece I would not
be too upset if black faux fur doesn't
do that well to be honest because if it
does do really well then we are going to
get so many copycats from other cliches
just like black clover is I mean black
clover is essentially you know big group
of cliches you know you have your
protagonist that wants to become the
Hokage wizard king king of the Pirates
whatever and his journey to do so he had
no powers now he has the best power ever
I mean that is that is annoying the
whole oh he has no powers but it's like
oh no well he was destined from the
start to have the greatest power and
then and that that just makes you think
like wait a second so am I supposed to
relate to this character because this
character tried really hard and
accomplished his goals
no no not at all this character was is
it you know lucky to act that he's
freaking demon powers and a magic
annulling sword I think there's just
another step of just doing something
that's real magic
have you noticed though the trend that
in shown an anime hair is the most you
know powerful thing of all time you know
if you have cool hair than your o piece
oh yeah oh you
you missed it you don't understand recon
you must learn to analyze anime better
young grasshopper allow me to explain my
comas pretty freakin powerful you're all
hair Goku pretty pretty bountiful insane
amounts of hair that changed color Lucy
how did he get his powers
what about Luke's your mistake no no say
Tama had hair but now a dim bulb he he
had his powers while he had hair but
then you decided to shave it off Oh No
Saitama lost his hair because how hard
he trained that's right
yeah but based most hours you know what
I've noticed I think I think you're onto
something with it's a hair thing but I
think it's only the overkill Shonen that
have the hair thing thank you all my
tear to get his powers did you not find
that hair yeah hey this is sarcastic not
talking because I want all the Shaolin
powers I want to be maybe not you know
the crybaby protagonist but maybe that
cool guy that he looks up to it's like I
want to be like this guy I want to be
the king of the anime youtubers when you
stop flicking your hair back then you
gotta start using the gel and going
straight up like ah no that's only when
I go you have to have it you have to
have it go forward can you somehow it's
a spike forward and like yeah it's funny
after I blow dry my hair when I'm
blow-drying it it can like like go like
all over here like it's it's a mess I
just want to mess up his hair so bad
right now I just it looks very anime
example you can't see anything never
world it's very nice and cold and like
well cold I just like he doesn't call me
just splashes of water and it just puts
it all the way to the back correct we're
not guys animating
correct Animax t-shirts and mugs oh look
I have
lucky for you I'm a nurse idea well put
your hair school and your on your
t-shirt so so yeah so people can be
inspired with your hairstyle
with the beard and glasses and
everything oh that's that's a good idea
put your face that's such a Power Move
put your face come on not that
egotistical yet to just sell a shirt
with just my face on it
what there's time there's time I get at
a point where I'm like did you bro I
think I'm the greatest thing ever and I
just like put my face on it in the
darker shades for we'll see we'll see
any other Shonen that we should discuss
it's wrong to make videos ranting ever
end or something like that
seven deadly sins is coming up yeah is
back January 2018 season two people
still think that it's season 3 D because
of the Netflix disaster but no this is
season 2 Netflix for episodes were just
an OVA or TV special but you can think
of it as an ova same [ __ ] basically not
just for additional episodes filler for
additional episodes with an awesome
theme song that no one remembers because
it was only four episodes see that's
another exert some times I feel that you
know they're just like overkill you know
what I mean like there's so much
fanservice so much of the same cliches
you know exactly what's going to be
happening because you know it's a shown
in you feel like you always can detect
what's going to be happening in the
future and I feel like people get bored
with that that's the reason probably why
they're stretching this out hoping that
people don't catch on but to catch a gun
because they read the manga well you're
making this again there's a shounen is a
huge genre huge you're only talking
about the particular battle shonan's
that like long-running Shonen in this
because I'm particularly interested in
are we going to get more long-running
successful shonan's
or is this era becoming just like a cuz
I'm building up a long-running shown in
is a commitment right by the manga
companies like the magazine they have to
actually really put faith in this and
commit to a certain amount of
length the anime same thing they have to
commit to it and sometimes it's better
for them financially you just go for the
short-term profit so do a 13 episode
adaptation that's like heavy on
fanservice but doesn't take much work
nips and let you come into 50 episodes
right so that's that's what I'm
wondering are we going to enter an age
where is just like short small
adaptations for that short-term seasonal
profit rather than investing in a long
anime even if it doesn't take off right
away because they want eventually to
have a loyal following well you never
know but they need to do something
different already with these anime you
they can't just keep putting out more
black clovers because black clover is is
a cliche it's pick it up right like what
what well you can pick up and you can
sense in the situation like you know
what's going to happen before it happens
yeah then there are shown in anime that
are very different than the norm that do
really well like Gintama it's a totally
not normal Shonen Gintama or JoJo's or
can take you hitman reborn they're all
different style shonan's I want to shown
it with a little lolly sister in it
yuu-yuu hakusho hunter hunter all these
are not your cliche we all just pretend
we didn't hear what recon said recon
didn't say anything and you can hear
what recon said be sure to smash that
like button we need to we need to stop
anyways it's late how every every trend
that goes through you have a different
one when you're doing my here I could
name me a Detroit smash that like button
and when you're doing Dragon Ball super
videos it's hit that like button yeah
you get it you get you're trying to
punish into liking your videos my
brilliant meta [ __ ] yeah one punch man
one punch that like button yeah
Code Geass is coming and now subscribe
viewers all of you I command you sir
no way I did it in one of the videos yes
that's hilarious my sarcastic actually I
had I did an effect where like Geass
actually showed up in my eye because I
was on camera it's a video I thought it
was brilliant but of course I'm more
sanguine I think I don't know someone in
the child I'm not sure if it was
dramatic or someone asked if because you
mentioned Knox
all the cliches with black clover and
how it just takes a bunch of different
concepts from different currently
popular Shonen and kind of throws them
together and I agree I think it's
definitely there he was saying what if
black lover was just like a satire of
the Shonan John John Ryan was just doing
that as a satire would you enjoy that
and I mean it depends how it's done
personally I joined Kona Suba as a
satire of the izakaya genre which
definitely needed to be sat tired
because it's so oversaturated so I
thought that was great but yeah with
black for I don't know I don't know
right I don't find it funny at all it's
cringy to the nth degree that hasta
needs to declare his love for sister
Lily oh that was like 30% of the first
three episodes sister marry me I thought
it was cute cuz he's like a kid at first
otherwise if he was an adult it would
have been like no he just kept he just
kept on saying this for years I mean we
saw the episode of black clover when
sister Lily first of all showed up but
for the first time and asked the so
young who's like oh god please marry me
and until the very moment we are right
now he still wants to marry her it's
just like so cliche to me it's almost
like he's like a love child a freaking
luffy and sandy like nice you know
there's a lot of Lachey's know you're
100% right like I said you know my the
fact that he doesn't have power and then
he has the strongest
power deck whoo 101 the fact that he
wants to be the wizard King is like
Pirate King and like wizard and Maggie
and you know Naruto Hokage all that
stuff is just thrown in there
yeah I was trying to I'm starting to
think that the only reason why asked the
wants to be wizard king is just to
impress sister Lily that's it I'm wizard
King now it would have been funny is
that all mr. Genie now you get to be
with me funny thing was like I'm gonna
impress her by being the greatest priest
I'm gonna be such a great priest guys
it's like the priest anime like you know
they have like these nice anime like
ballroom anime it's like this guy just
anime because he will not be able to get
his [ __ ] thank you well depends like
with Orthodox Christians our priests can
marry is just Catholics can't right and
I know with like Jewish rabbis can marry
and all that stuff but yeah it's
interesting because speaking of priests
anime I remembered blue exorcist and I
remember watching it and thinking when I
was watching and thinking like they were
all yawn right so it was all the girls
were like young so I didn't
there was no fanservice for me because
I'm that I didn't find them obviously
they're too young to be attractive but
there was this is a cartoon so they
could be attractive but it was funny
because I was like I noticed that this
cartoon doesn't really have you know the
same it doesn't have that much
fanservice and then BAM they throw into
one teacher chick yeah it's not like
with like huge boobs just like yeah
cheering nothing pops into it in season
2 I forgot her name
there's the fanservice but blue exorcist
I was like what is happening with blue
exorcist it's like every religion is in
blue exorcist and they're all real
somehow I mean you have you they're
Hindus and then there's the Shaolin
monks and then that's cool you know and
all of them have their own different you
know things they somehow work together
to fight say
there's no such thing according to the
Shaolin monks there's no such thing as
Satan I know yeah they just do what
everything in there I agree
by the way anime fan boy says the best a
Sakai is minecraft that's true
minecraft could isn't a Sakaya not
enough Aronson in Minecraft
no there isn't barely any harem Oh nope
oh actually you can build your harem
have you ever made a Minecraft a harem
nobody loved oh yeah one thing I really
don't like is how some these anime that
I thought had great potential like the
devil is a part-timer and that I'm only
getting 13 episodes and I loved it you
saw was so good that's why that's why I
worried that like you know we're just
going for that quantity over quality so
instead of committing more to an anime
like that mr.brother anime shows and
those shoulder probably suck but it
doesn't matter as long as they get that
initial pipe and sales and whatever I
don't know well I just gotta love how
he's just [ __ ] working in a
McDonald's every main characters works
in McDonald's McDonald's yes the whole
thing right the whole thing was just
about him work it's like so many scenes
where just about was just about him
working in [ __ ] McDonald's that shows
hilarious yeah that's something we can
agree on Knox I definitely thought the
devil was a partner was a hilarious show
watching I didn't know what to expect
because that was one of the shows that I
just saw our end to be on Netflix yeah
same here I was like well this is an
anime let's check this out so I didn't
know any hype about it and then I was
like you know this is actually hilarious
oh yeah yeah if I disappointed didn't
have more episodes cuz some with some
anime like oh he's that guy anime right
there yeah that's a reverse okay that's
interesting yeah but with like an anime
like Otto Hana
it has 13 episodes but it like it has 11
episode
okay but you feel like it's complete so
that's fine but with the show like that
like Dell is a part-timer it definitely
has the potential to be like a
long-running type of Shonen but it never
got that chance which sucks it doesn't
really have that much of an a chance to
become long-running I mean every single
guy Satan fights he destroys in like
three seconds flat I mean that's the
whole reason why though that's really
great I loved it but I can't see that
going on for a hundred episodes know
what the reason like having him do that
so much with the very first bit of
episodes that were thrown at you if they
were to continue on and do a second
season it would be more shocking to take
about characters that he couldn't defeat
you know what I mean
say God sent to the show no one wants to
see him fight a character he can't
defeat let's be honest whole angel
selling burgers no it is we want to see
him lose for a reason and today we get
back up and get stronger that is what
makes a good story no you don't
understand my I prefer the main
character to actually lose instead of
winning straight away well I agree with
you if it wasn't a comedy like I don't
want to ever see one punch man lose okay
exactly a punch man just one punch is
everyone wins it would be funny it would
be funny you can add a comical sense to
having a villain that's really really
hard for them to beat and they help they
lose a couple times say they have to
come back once or twice they could have
had a lot more comedy and make the joke
longer running you know and I mean
exactly I agree
all the times in that anime that he was
almost about to lose was because for
some reason he had no powers at the
moment yeah so think if he really was
about to be knocked down on his ass and
to the point where you know you could
add all of these comical sad tires to it
maybe put some sad tires from other
anime you know what I mean with fighting
scenes when heroes are about to be at
this point put a cliche lines and you
know what I mean I think I can I think
we can definitely say that Knox loses
this round
Knox wins I think Dux loses this because
in the fantasy world within the devil's
apart Amida they create there's
definitely a lot of ways to make
challenges to him as the devil because
they have saw all sorts of magic and
stuff happening and things that they
could potentially be I mean I'm not
saying that we met it like met the
potential opponents but there's plenty
of room to grow in future seasons if
they had more seasons so I think the
potential was there also Sharia says
hashtag Anna McDonald's I have to shout
that out because that was also up Kings
like one punch I remember that you know
he got video hilarious one of my
favorite videos of last year was that oh
how about we talk about high Q is a
shounen but it's not really going on I
don't know if there's gonna be and there
is there is another season is it
scheduled or there just have material
what it isn't the ending is open and
they're still gonna continue in the port
does not mean that it's getting another
season you don't realize this at this
point but it has to man if it does I
know I'm gonna be so thank you it's
pretty much awesomeness my I guess so
JoJo's part 5 is coming eventually
JoJo's can we please not talk about Jojo
this is business
this happens every day like I respect
knucks and then he starts talking about
JoJo's mind how about we talk about
maybe overload how about Overlord that's
a good one
yeah overlord Fiona who is coming up
what nuts I don't think it's a shounen
I'm pretty sure it is no it's a shounen
like that that was a fart term as a Sean
it's not like up it's not like your
traditional battles Shonen but it's
interesting though because well I still
stand by what I said I think overlords
overhyped overrated
I think overlord is good I don't think
it's overhyped I don't think it's nice
it's a good show I'm gonna say the Lord
is not mainstream but it's a good show a
lot it's it got a lot of hype some yeah
I really do
try it out I really do want right over
door because I don't think it's the next
like attack on Titan in terms of hype or
anything like that but I think it's a
good show for what it is I don't think
it's over hype dogs I do I only hear
people talking good about it I don't
hear anyone because it's a good show
yeah I don't hear any bad reviews on it
whatsoever I think that's why people are
fine with one hand being held off
because a lot of people were more
excited for season 2 of that you know
what I mean if I find would if I would
expect people to complain about Overlord
now I would find out that they've
probably been saying like who is too
powerful he's not losing any battles
he's so old P yeah that's the only
complaint I would think people would say
kind of like I'm like Kirito and since
you love Kirito that's not an issue for
you know I love carried on Keros my boy
well I expect I fully expect Knox to
make a sarcastic trailer for overlord
were at the beginning he lies and says
this enemy is gonna be so the way more
than his deserves to but in reality is
thinking it's getting insulted just as
much as it deserves to cuz he's a liar I
say that at the beginning of all of them
sort of cover my ass yeah but I'm just
saying you you life and I was gonna do
honest descriptions on it not a
sarcastic trailing oh I'm a sarcastic
fact but honest description versus
sarcastic facts is an honest description
more like when you have a bunch of stuff
to say like with Naruto arcs how are you
gonna do it I don't don't think I have a
bunch of stuff to say about overlord I
feel like the fact format would work
better I'd love to hear little arcs so I
would just do it like that
okay yeah I do look forward to it
because I do want to see your take on it
well I always like seeing your take
knucks cuz your quality youtuber man I
ain't scription along with the rest of
these fine folks but before we go of
today I will do want to ask you guys
what kind of shown
animal would you like to see in the
future if you could just decide one day
okay I want to see this type of shown
anything like something that you haven't
seen so far that you think would be good
or sudden you haven't seen in a while do
you think should make a comeback saying
thanks you guys in the chat let me know
what you guys want to see in a new
Shonen anime slash manga in the future
but I don't know whoever wants to go
please go ahead
youtubers Shonen i want to see a
long-running a sekai Shonen where there
are humans a few of them not just one
that are trapped in an e sekai world and
they have to adapt and they want to help
this world because for whatever reason
the political structure of the world is
insane and so they take it upon
themselves well not really if taken upon
themselves they sort of get everyone
falls into like a different category
they have different ideas and how they
want to develop the world and whatever
but then they have to train to get
stronger that way it could be long
running and until eventually each one
has their own ideals and they save the
day so you're saying no game no life but
actually good is what you're saying
yeah no I'm not saying no game no life
at all because that's what I was saying
what I was not saying what I was
suggesting is let's say there are five
humans or whatever that get trapped in
this other world for whatever reason
either it's prophecy or it's chance I
don't know I didn't actually write a
story I'm just sort of pulling his out
of my ass but and they're in like this
whole other world thingy one guy becomes
this rebel dude and one guy tries to
grow in the military of some other
country I don't know and their political
is going on the one thing this is
missing is something unique a unique
power that each of the five of them has
oh I ever did this power to gain their
status and fight each other I'm not
disagreeing with you I don't have a
whole story here written well for next
rank of Fame Knox I want you to come up
with a great power idea that we can
steal from you mmm-hmm um for the Etowah
recon
anything you want to see in the future
in terms of Shonen
oh I would want to see Cleary tell next
generation no that's not what I'm gonna
say I don't even want to see any of the
the current ones but I want to see
something from the top of my imagination
I want to see a long-running harem ed
she Shonen what that's the thing recon
if it's like how do you mean is it harem
where all of them are with the guy in a
relationship at the same time and
they're cool with it or is it one of
those harems no no I would like a more
progressive it's anime is about shown in
battle Mormons
I would say it's more you know
progressive relationship than the main
kind of famous recon the whole point of
harem is he goes through different girls
and then chooses one you're saying you
want a long-running show knit where he
never chooses there is only you can do
that exactly you can done it though that
is so boring
so a lot of this you are going to love
me for this it's a long-running Issa chi
Shonen but he's trapped in another
universe where they're only girls oh
there we go that would justify why girls
would be cool with all being with one
guy at the same time because they're
actually exactly there we go recon i
just basically put your dream into
format [ __ ] you man and the guy the guy
is like a shy like so he doesn't know
how to approach girls but that's okay
because they just approach him because
he's the only guy so he's like yeah
what's up girls
yeah I don't now I got it you're lucky
I'm not spoiling anything in one piece
right now thank you
look serious I'm very it's really really
really hard like because everybody like
I have a lot of friends that like it and
they post memes and stuff and I try to
avoid pictures and look I know the same
person
I'm freaking out like I never say this
guy Lily yes guys I stopped caring about
spoilers a long time ago because it's if
you're following anime news or just like
videos and something that there's no way
there's no way you can care about
spoilers especially like it's a show
that's popular but maybe you haven't
gotten to it yet like it like you said
with one piece it's like there's no way
stop this stuff you beat me this time
not beat me this time I always beat you
no no you lost no I'm steadfast in my
opinion no no you convinced me now um
also now you mentioned earlier a YouTube
anime youtubers Shonen and funny you
said that because someone did say in the
chat about a shounen where I am trying
to become the YouTube anime YouTube King
and so I have to murder people probably
I assume and have like I don't know like
have a kid that thinks I got it all and
then you find any one's up doing it you
know what I mean anime you want to
become the number one youtuber of all
time the wizard king of youtubers I
should say and so what you do is you
just write scripts because your genius
mind needs to do that other lackeys not
like your brother of course can do the
editing and so you start pawning it off
to smaller you know separate companies
and whatever you don't every one of your
618 editors are your little sister but
not related by blood guys but not really
die knocks I think I think you are onto
something there I think you're onto
something
also we can have like a guy let's call
him I don't know digit Rafi Pinocchio
from Alexia and he's like this really
nice dude
man's name George and I pretend to be
his friend but then I like usurp his his
power
crunchy my neck see you might be
watching this yeah yeah you gotta take
George you know and he's young and he
doesn't know anything and he believes he
can't do it and then he meets crunchy
Crow nexia you know what I mean and and
then you know and then throughout a long
time he winds up figuring out like who's
on a side who's against own you know
what I mean who supports look I'm sorry
but that sounds so cliche know what to
be honest to be honest this is the good
part when the battles go down it's not
YouTube anymore it's like dead tube that
yeah I definitely honest everyone gets
trapped into YouTube there we go more
realistic everyone's trapped in YouTube
and they have to kill each other to
survive there's less whoever collects
the 15 ruining my true I like it I like
it so it's like survival make it
survival internet YouTube thing and the
more subscribers you have the higher
your power level is right yeah it's like
by you but you can be shady and make
friends with bigger youtubers and then
backstab them and like this score your
discord server is like your kingdom
so everywhere everyone on YouTube
everyone in the end community makes a
video and so each week you make one
video only whoever gets the highest
views on that video will survive each
one will survive with the first one the
lowest views the press with the lowest
views gets eliminated that's don't you
you can't do that that's dead - that's
exactly copying off that - yeah dad -
well no they get you take the crime
whatever anybody does like they have a
they have a trending list
and who's ever on the top of the
trending z' list are the ones who don't
get punished who's ever on the bottom of
the trending list are the ones who
actually wind up taking on all the
punishment for the crime so if anybody
killed anybody raped anybody or did
anything all the crime goes on that
person okay but what's a survive oh it's
really fast up to it's really good so
really amazing Who am I I don't want to
live in the world where young pretend
president decide to sign up you can't
either be a viewer or a viewer or a
player by the way any of you watching
Kings game I wish all the more recent
episodes I find it pretty unbearable I'm
not watching it yeah I've heard bad
things from Knox and Misty so that's why
I haven't really gone into it it's very
good well if you say it's very good that
I'm definitely not gonna watch but
disome back you know animate for never
world situation and that would be a
crazy anime arc I tell you that right
now
no Naruto Sasuke next level [ __ ] right
there yeah but yeah man I think I
actually like this idea of like can I
butcher you tubers together and like you
have to make a video and I'll drop it
within the same week and then see who
gets the most views and that presents a
problem because the most the bigger
channels will get more views yeah but
that's the thing let's say you take
comparable channels so you don't get
like everybody you get comparable
channels and then where is the most
views gets some out career prize though
like you would have to like all pitch in
that's that sounds like an interesting
competition thank you thank you very
much
I only had a decent idea I liked it
Thank You ina my thank you now we're
just gonna have to wait for someone to
make it ooh
okay well we'll talk about him guys
infinite gaming says he loves my content
thank you so much my friend and everyone
be sure to check out the other youtubers
here linked in the description also
merge voice we got that merged I'll link
in the description leave a like if you
like rank of Fame before we go and thank
you all obviously everyone in the chat
who showed up and have a great
discussion as always
including the anime dude who try to
troll me again about suddenly since them
an anime dude
Michael NOx
what do you do hi I'm max ha I do anime
content on YouTube like most of the
other people here sarcastic stuff
analytical stuff and moreover stuff that
recon gets pissed off about which is a
win in my books
Thank You baking of Regan Regan one of
my boys it's your boy recon and I do
them anime ranking lists and top tens oh
yeah
spoilers he's also known as recon no
pico yes yes after dark channels I don't
recommend anyone checking on that one
and he hasn't seen the mugs so I thought
you might like this one there Mac got
multiple multiple mods going on over
here
yes now to end it off now oh god I tell
us who you are and what you do and how
you're getting over that cold I follow
your Twitter so I saw the you thank you
I'm feeling a lot better
and I actually am doing anime news and
funny skits right now but soon I am
going to be in animations and deviling
and animations like actual work action
stuff well that's that's like a year or
two down the road but I'm gonna be doing
like short story of time animations and
stuff like that nice some people this is
a question people like as we gear up to
and be like oh [ __ ] or as anime I gotta
[ __ ] off for doing that [ __ ] we'll have
to find out but yeah that sounds
interesting nah well I definitely look
forward to that would be quite
interesting to see so yeah and I'm a
clicking where's that mute button on
recon no am i doing exactly that
I'm trying to talk distract you guys
from drugs I wonder I wonder guys he's
gonna be like knocks oh no I will not
accept this
I will not [ __ ] accept this by the
way guys thank you again for joining
thank you everyone in the shot as always
and you guys here on the panel it's
always a pleasure
until next time High School DxD sucks
recon what see dusk you